speaking of the fbi and you know the fbi
has that that tv show about the fbi
agents the x-files and it's about aliens
a harvard professor says alien technique
that's a great segment
hey smooth compliment you on that one
yeah it was so good i'm i'm so good at
podcasting
uh we got this crazy story it's it's so
you know uh and then we'll we'll go
super chat to this but check out the
story this is this is crazy i really
want to talk about this
harvard professor says alien technology
visited our solar system in 2017.
he also says they're coming back in his
upcoming book extraterrestrial the first
sign of intelligent life beyond earth
theoretical physicist avi loeb lays out
his theory about a peculiar shaped
object that has entered our solar system
several years ago
the intersection the inner stellar
object named
um was first observed through the pan
stars telescope in hawaii's haleakala
observatory in 2017. researchers
observed that it passed through the uh
ecliptic plane on september 6 from the
direction of vega
a star in the lira constellation that is
about 25 light years away from our
planet
just three days later um hawaiian for
scout
began accelerating toward the sun before
it eventually came closer to earth on
october 7th
moving swiftly towards the constellation
pegasus and the blackness beyond
some scientists claimed um which is
believed to be the first interstellar
object detected in our solar system
was simply another comet however loeb
the chairman of the heart of harvard
university's astronomy department
dismisses that assumption
and as it relies too much on the
familiar what would happen if a caveman
saw a cellophone
you wondered he'd seen rocks all his
life he would have thought it was just a
shiny rock
loeb says that there are two big details
that suggest umama wasn't just a comet
but a piece of alien technology the
first detail is the object's dimensions
as it was determined to be five to ten
times longer than it was wide
loeb argues the cigar-like shape isn't
typical for natural space object
but the theoretical physicist lays the
biggest detail that supports his theory
is the movement the excess push away
from the sun
that was the thing that broke the
camel's back loeb explains the sun's
gravitational force would cause a
natural object to move faster
as it approaches and eventually push the
object back causing it to move slower as
it moves away
low points out that this didn't occur
with um which accelerated slightly
but to a highly statistically
significant extent
if we are not alone are we the smartest
kids on the block he asks
if there was a species that eliminated
itself through war or changing the
climate
we can get our we can get our act
together before uh and behave better
instead we are wasting a lot of
resources on earth fighting each other
and other negative things that are a big
waste
he said also for coming back this is not
the first
story we got this year about aliens
being real and coming to earth and now
the head of harvard's astra
was astronomy department yeah has said
yeah
aliens are real so uh we talked we
talked about revelations a little bit
but what if it's uh
what if aliens are coming well some
religious people believe
those are demonic entities some
conspiracy theorists believe otherwise
some people say it's advanced technology
but
it really does kind of feel like they're
prepping us for something i mean we had
that
uh head of the israeli space program we
had these recent new revelations we have
the event that just happened in hawaii
we have the disclosure which is supposed
to happen
in about a hundred and eighty days
that's in the coveted relief bill we'll
clarify that yeah
somehow in the covid r the covet omnibus
the spending bill
was uh the intelligence authorization
act which included
from the time of passing the bill 180
days the pentagon must release all their
information on ufos
so they've been slow rolling this we
just saw a crazy ufo in west virginia we
did a segment about it it looked nuts
people saying it was a flaming ufo
crashing to earth or something
but uh i don't know everybody's been
speculating aliens are coming
what do you guys think i think i think
it's a mixture
i think uh if you take a look at world
war ii with roswell you know coming out
of that how nasa came out you know
there definitely was like this
technological boom in advancement
because the nazis were obviously
involved with like black magic and adolf
hitler was obsessed with that like
obtaining
even the scientists like crazy nazi
scientists that were obsessed with
you know communicating with off-world
entities or whatever they called them
some people believe they're demons in
order to obtain like crazy scientific
nah
like knowledge and astrophysics and all
these things a lot of people believe
that's how the atom bomb came
into reality but americans got to it
first but
i think it is interesting how there's
always this connection
with technology and like off-world
entities
and if you take a look at from a
biblical perspective like you said i
mean the bible does make it very clear
that you know we wrestle not against
flesh and blood but against
spiritual hosts of wickedness and
principalities and powers but
i just want to point out how there
always is
i'll tell you this let's get let's have
a little bible study
the number one thing that i believe when
you take a look at the garden of eden
where eve was deceived what was the one
thing that he tempted her with
one thing was that she would have some
kind of super knowledge
there's always some kind of temptation
with an expert knowledge or
a knowledge that goes further or wisdom
that takes you beyond
like dmt exactly and that's what that's
what i'm that's what i'm saying is like
they're always
whenever there's ufos involved or some
kind of spiritual entities involved
there's always this
offer of like an advanced knowledge and
then an advancement in technology and i
think
i don't have you guys seen the bob lazar
documentary on netflix oh yeah right
so i definitely think there is some kind
of technological advancement i mean
have you guys seen like throughout
trump's presidency he'll come out and
say
if you guys he'll threaten nations he'll
be like if you guys keep doing this you
guys are going to see like
you know rain and fire like the world
has never seen before i definitely and
then the space force came
right i definitely think we have
something that other nations don't know
what it is
but where that knowledge came from i
personally believe is supernatural
can we talk about like what supernatural
is in aliens or
i believe demonic beings can we talk
about can we talk about that you said
with dmt and i don't want to get
like too druggy here but
but like one thing that's interesting is
like i didn't become a
christian until i was like 19 and i'm
still learning a lot uh but
one thing i can say is i was agnostic
before then as agnostic as a teenager
could be
but i rejected a lot of spiritual things
my my background is in science i went to
university and that i've always been
a man about like you know the physical
and what you can measure and the methods
that go
into that something that science no
longer is um
but i remember that one interesting
thing that that i didn't expect to was
to kind of get into experimenting with
drugs
growing up and you know i remember doing
drugs like ecstasy or smoking pot and
those were fun
uh but i remember i remember the first
time that i did
i did mushrooms uh you know i was
younger
and i remember there was nothing like
that that i'd ever done in my life and
the psilocybin and that feeling
i every drug that i had consumed every
substance kind of
numbed or altered reality but i had
never felt like
i wasn't myself before living in a new
world until i had taken mushrooms
and i think trying a bunch of you know
psychedelics in those years like lsd
even like five and meow
dipped and all those experimental ones
that were coming out to cb
i think there was one time where i just
took way too many mushrooms you know
like just
too many where you just done that yeah
just too many
and uh like i remember having like a
mental break
like a mental breakdown like i didn't
believe in spirits or anything but
no lie i went into my friend's bathroom
way to do this your parents are asleep
you're in the living room you take a
bunch of mushrooms wise decision
and a total 16 year old wisdom there
guys i remember like i went into the
restroom and this like
this being appeared and was telling me
to stick my head into the toilet and
drown myself
and like to kill myself and i felt like
the only way to escape what was going on
was to die and as much as it might just
sound like it was like a bad trip
i felt for a moment like real in that
moment and i felt like i woke up
and these i looked at the being in this
restroom and i can remember that it's
like a long restroom
and it was like a dark like a like a
dark force
and i remember that i had never felt so
oppressed and you know for years after
that instance i struggled with suicide
i was heavily depressed but i wasn't on
mushrooms anymore
and i started to like wake up to like
the fact that there might be something
else out there
because why is it that i'm no longer
high but these feelings that i first
experienced while
in that toilet you know are staying with
me
and i think that there's some validity
to the fact that
i think that spirits are real i think
that there is something that is
that is genuinely real and out there i
know a lot of people say it's not true
that it's just a trick of the mind or a
hallucination but the reality speaking
is when you talk about people's trips on
on hallucinogens why do they all see the
same things
you know why is this not an uncommon
experience where people see dark forces
the devil
i mean but coming into this with aliens
it's like i just we're all human
no well it depends it's not all unison
it's not all the same but some people
have positive effects on people i had
i had positive effects mostly i'm just
saying but when you come down to this i
started like
realizing there could be more and i
think that i had a genuine conversion
experience while i was sober
when i was 19 i was on the toilet i'm
not now i'm joking i was on the toilet
and i was writing this book why grace
changes everything not trying to become
a christian
not trying to like it wasn't like in
some like ten revival meeting it wasn't
emotional
and then i just like something clicked
where like i realized that all the pain
that i felt the depression everything
could be forgiven in a moment you can
say that i was you know that it was fake
but it was real to me
that i felt something shift in my mind
and my heart that i can't ever deny
where i began to become aware that god
was real he was in my life and i've
never been the same
and so sometimes i wonder the people
that doubt that there's something else
out there maybe it's just they haven't
experienced anything real
or they've been around so many frauds
who are trying to you know sell
something to them or like
you know they they're just basing off of
a hallucination that that's why they
don't believe i think there's like a
split in that i'm i've
met people who have told me that uh
they've
communicated with other beings or
something like that like i had one guy
who told me that he was a drug addict
he was wasting his life and then one day
he was in the woods and he felt a voice
inside of him coming out asking him what
are you doing why are you doing this
and that was a profound spiritual
experience where he became
very very christian and then turned his
life around got off drugs
started working and he was just like
some punk rock dude he kept to
you know his love of punk rock but he
opened a business and he just totally
got away from drugs
and he was like i know you won't believe
me when i say that it happened
it doesn't matter it happened to me it's
my experience i can tell you what i
experienced and it's your choice if you
want to believe it or not
and he was like and i understand most
people hear that are going to say that's
crazy there's no way that happened and
he's like but i'm telling you
a voice came from the center of my being
telling me this and i was like i mean i
believe you but there's two ways to
explain it you had a spiritual response
because uh another worldly being was
telling you you're destroying your life
or
you took too many drugs either way it
helped you so
it's a positive thing i think you know
just kind of roll with it and i'm i'm
not going to come out right on your
parade
and be like no you're wrong you're crazy
i'm going to be like hey man you're
doing really well for yourself you've
turned things around
whatever it was it worked and it helped
you yeah i think we also need to realize
that everything is
energy we're very energetic and to think
that it's only in the dimensions that we
see it under
it's kind of naive because there's a lot
more happening that we don't even
perceive
see or feel and there's even a lot of
theories out there
and even official scientific studies
that talked about how
it could have been things like
psychedelics like mushrooms that have
propelled civilizations
that might have actually started
religions that might have actually
uh i don't know about that one uh do you
have a specific reference that
i'm saying about people doing drugs
going crazy and then well it depends
well we have
meth which is you know it depends what
you also
see as a drug because again people see
psychedelics in
in a scientific term not just as you
know a drug that you take for fun
but there also have been a lot of
medical studies recently that correlate
a lot of significance when it comes to
brain development and dealing with
issues like ptsd and depression
that have been very profound and very
important when it comes to this kind of
psychedelic space which kind of
according to many people merges this
physical and spiritual world and lets
people see this
veil whether good or not and i think
it's i and i think personally my own
personal opinion there is something way
bigger
there is something greater there are
entities that are good there are
entities that are bad and i think
i i think that's something that i
personally believe positive negative
like that's one thing that i've always
questioned and maybe you can help me
with this
when you see people like claim to have
experiences with spiritual beings taking
aside the totally kooky people who
you're just going you're grifting you're
trying to get money or you're selling me
something let's take
genuine experiences whether it's on
ayahuasca or it's like a
christian experience or even some sort
of like a buddhist experience let's take
the spiritual
usually it's like kind of like the
extreme where it's like some i
encountered some being and it either
really freaked me the heck out and it
put me into a downward spiral or a
my whole life changed for the positive
it's not just like yo so i was walking
down this
thing was like i'm carl how do you like
mexican candy and i was like yeah
stuff's pretty salty but good and we
went our ways it's always like some
really extreme reaction and their life
changes
permanently everyone says my life
changed where's the where's the being
who appears and says
dude you're listening to the beatles
again that's overrated dude
zeppelin but you brought it way better
you brought up an important thing the
kind of extremes
of it and because of that a lot of
people paint these things as really good
or really bad
and we need to find the middle ground
here because you could have an
experience
that could be either or and you need to
understand them not just label them and
blame them
for for whatever is going on i have a
story
i was a youth pastor for about like five
years and i was doing like you know
vocational ministry
elijah could relate to this too is i
remember this one time
i was working on a bible study uh to
teach on this particular night
and uh i had it all laid out you know i
spent all night studying throughout the
night because i like to study throughout
the night you know
and uh i was up until maybe like four in
the morning and then the next morning
when i woke up i had to walk down the
street
in order to go pick up one of the cars
that was getting worked on at a mechanic
shop right
and uh i remember walking down the
street
and this random homeless guy just comes
out of nowhere that i've never seen
before never met before in my entire
life
and he walks up straight up to me and
he's like
so you believe in jesus random guy
and i'm like yeah and he starts to say
why why why are you going to go and do
what you're going to do tomorrow night
because we were going to give a bible
study we were going to feed people like
free tacos this and that
and he's like why are you going to go
there tomorrow night and do all those
nice things for those people
why are you gonna feed them why are you
gonna be good to them you think you
think that
that god really cares about that stuff
and i'm like okay
and then out of nowhere he starts to
just straight up he recited
my almost my entire bible study
entire bible study to my face everything
i was going to teach on
that following day starts blaspheming
the teaching
as if the guy was in my room the night
before watching me study
the entire night long and when you take
a look at demonic
you know uh entities and the way that
they interact with people in the
scripture
is they always blaspheme christ and they
blaspheme anything that has anything to
do with christ
and a lot of people don't understand
that you know in distant religions
they'll call them watchers or or they'll
call them you know the ones that are
always listening in but
people need to realize that whatever
your interpretation is
of it is why does it always have to
blaspheme god or blaspheme christ
and i kind of want people to just think
about that that are listening to this
right now
because i find it interesting those and
i could tell you guys some crazy stories
dude we've had kids in the ministry
12 year old 12 year old little kids
demon possessed out of their minds
eyes pitch black literally eyes pitched
like 12 year old little kid
about maybe 92 pounds 95 pounds
literally physically lifting up like
pastors
that probably weigh like two hundred and
thirty fifty possessed kids
possess kids speaking i've seen people
possess too i didn't believe until i saw
it
this yeah i'm dead serious this kid was
like 12 years old was speaking in a
grown man's voice
speaking in spanish perfect spanish
wasn't even hispanic
perfect spanish you saw that happen yeah
they were doing this this kid was in my
youth group
crazy demon possessed out of his mind
most americans believe in angels and
demons this is what i think
i think like as we talk i need to see
evidence man there's what i'm saying
there's there's a doubt in a lot of
people when it's gonna happen
but a lot of people a lot of people
believe in this and i think what's
happened is is that when you go to
when you go down to like some people
could call it mental illness but we've
really got to ask ourselves with the
alien question
you know it's so funny that like
christians always like you know oh
there's no aliens
but then they're telling everyone to
believe in angels and demons and then
you have these people who are like god's
not real there's no angels and demons
and they're like but there's aliens on
other planets it's like well it all
really shows something in
it's interesting in the human condition
and brain is that there's something
in us whether it's from conditioning or
something in nature
to where we like feel like there's
something else out there a lot of
america
more i think it's more americans than
not believe in this and so it's just an
interesting
thing to me is that these stories come
out the reason why they're even they're
publishing them is because they get
clicked on
right and it's just like but we can't
prove them per se unless you were like
maybe there with him
specifically so it's like i don't i
don't know what we can do here it's
trust i remember when i was uh when i
was like 19
i was talking to this religious guy so i
grew up catholic and then i left when i
was a kid
yeah you didn't know that no i didn't
know that either yeah yeah yeah catholic
school
and then uh but i once was a teenager
it was like out the window really really
atheist
then i met a guy and he asked me he was
like
you know we were talking about religion
and then he said how do you know you're
breathing
what are you breathing right now and i
was like air and he's like yeah yeah but
like what is it
and i was like combination of gases
carbon dioxide nitrogen oxygen mostly
nitrogen
he's like oh yeah crazy how do you how
do you know that and i was like i
learned it in school
and he was like but like did someone in
school tell it to you and i was like oh
my teacher brought it up we read in the
book and goes oh you read it in a book
you believe that book and i was like
yeah i do and he was like i read in the
book that jesus is the son of god and
that he came you know died for our sins
and all that stuff
is is my book wrong in your book right
and then i sort of laughed and i was
like i get your point
and his point was while they're
i think there's legitimate and valid
reasons to trust science
and why i will look at a science book
and talk about you know
elements and all that stuff people
have people in their lives they trust
they've experiences they've seen and
things they trust and they believe it
you haven't experienced what they
experience so you think something
different
how do you know they're wrong unless you
can prove a negative what you can't do
so it becomes very difficult
his ultimate point was like look man
there are a lot of people
that read this book i told them these
things and had people tell them that it
was true and they believe
that they believe it they've experienced
that the experts told them you think the
experts tell you but he's like when did
you pull an electron microscope and look
at that oxygen
that that that molecule that adam and i
was like i never did and he's like well
shouldn't you
if you want to believe in it and you
want to claim you need to see the
evidence when was the last time
anybody who claims to believe in science
actually did the experiment to prove it
to themselves they didn't
so before you start talking about how
you think someone else is wrong because
of their religion
the first thing you can do is actually
do the experiments to track radio waves
and you can do it you absolutely can do
it
but people don't do it is the point so
this guy wasn't like
a religious zelda or anything he's
making a point about philosophy and how
you've got a lot of people who think
they're smarter than other people and it
could be a religious person
who thinks they're smarter than those
who deny the religion and say oh you
just don't know what you're talking
about
and you've got these people who say oh
no you're crazy you're talking about i'm
smarter when in reality
it's just people who they trust what
they believe what they've experienced
and sometimes you can't change that it's
crazy though and it really you know
helped shape my view of everything
like you know this guy was pretty
religious but he's making his best
science is incomplete and i think that
that's where
with all these views when you read
stories about aliens where people come
into this
is i feel like this the question of
aliens is actually more philosophy and
spiritual than it is a scientific
question
a lot of people talk about science like
it's a religion you know like do you
believe in
in this and they don't realize that the
science is is so limited in the fact
that it's just testing
the physical world to you know through
hypotheses to create theories
and i think that people look at
scientists and bureaucrats today like
the bureaucrats are like
the priests or like the gods and the
scientists are somehow like the
theologians studying and predicting the
world
specifically right now with the left
saying the right doesn't believe in
science while they
literally ignore the lockdown science
and ignore the world health organization
they selectively choose what science
they support and what they oppose i'm
like i have a degree in science what do
you have and i ask people that i mean
it's not that extensive but it's like
to be honest it's like i can tell you
that it's genuinely a very limited thing
but science today isn't even science
it's just predictive programming of like
whatever they want you to believe in
science today it's very political
yeah but i'm just saying for a long time
and that's and that's the left who have
been i i just worked for
environmental nonprofits and the left
was always complaining about researchers
that were paid off by
you know major corporations that's what
they've
all those those scientists do that study
well they were paid off by big oil and
i'm like okay
like well so you don't believe the
science is that report wrong for your
political reason
that's why i've always been like yo
these people just want power
they'll claim the sciences on their side
if it supports what they want
that's just about it thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you